welcome to this video I'm playing Nico
here from france the french defence
french defence the dutch defense the 50
is from France and we are playing the
Dutch defense interesting 97 here I have
a nice trick g6 Bishop f5 I know I am
probably easily spotted no it's not
easily spotted okay then I'll take it
Queen h5 checkmate okay so should I just
retreat probably yeah the question is
how to keep the position open yeah maybe
maybe c3 is ok I'd like to not only have
the porn but also get active play going
in with HOH 5 this is this okay though I
don't don't mind this setup can you play
five I can question is is it any good I
probably just go here
I'll still be five coming up no can
he takes 8h takes g3 there is some
combined play with our interesting can
now also take here why not yeah at least
the H farlis is closed but why does two
bonds up basically for nothing much of
compensation
Queen f6 maybe no okay yeah the question
is can I can i really just keep this
this material I can't make it just night
at 3am and that creature for many f4
there really is no attack I think I
don't believe in a night f4 or something
like that queen bee six maybe then maybe
queen bee six switching back to
attacking the e pawn okay yeah I would
see what what type of attacking movie
will play he must do something drastic
anyway if he gives me time for castling
Knight f3 it's basically resign herbal
right coming to d4 or something like
that is just very easily winning so we
must do something drastic take on f4 g5g
five looks crazy but something very
directly maybe Queen Queen to be six
going to be six could be really
something yeah and I didn't really see
this beforehand night f1 looks best but
it is after night f4 it's definitely
something going on
tim keeney 21 maybe you look at four mm
maybe you can take a look at four cakes
Knight takes Queen of three now four I
should have played that for when i
played this I didn't really see Queen B
6 this is just returning muth now I had
other move certainly I can just let him
take this back and I'll just keep my
extra point with a good position sir and
for was it wasn't really greedy in a
sense I was just not if I would have
seen Queen B 6 I wouldn't have played
that form yeah yeah there there is stuff
like that hmm ok takes Knight takes but
what exactly is happening I don't Bishop
g4 maybe it's could be M
night f4 creaking f3 can also go to g1 I
can also give the check first yeah
Bishop g4 check where I can have you won
cakes I can go to check one anyway if i
go here Queen III desk weenie one Bishop
h3 maybe takes Queen III
if i go to f3 that's really Bishop g4
check I can take Knight f3 why I cannot
calculate this happens I go here we
should yeah you can go to 83 maybe takes
Queen III that's really terrible 23
takes their time morning don't don't see
a checkmate at the moment but there is
probably one they are exactly this takes
Queen III and it's got look f8 also in
the mix if i go to g1 here Queenie three
maybe that's better but it's got look f1
on top of all the worst is it is very
easy to play here 93m very easy or easy
to see I have no no defense they are
when 93 as the easiest
check between f2 it's all winning check
very little hope that he misses
something check check check
white resigns yeah for us I simply
overlooked queen bee six the term it is
any move other than air force of course
very very good for white but I
overlooked that you can go back to be
six other than that f4 is okay something
like this is very close to resign over
for black he has absolutely no play for
for this two bonds two points for
nothing can try this you can even just
cancel on you it's very simple I just so
I just didn't see Quinn b6 those kind of
sacrifices are not working but queen bee
success immediately making it a tricky
yeah maybe I should have played Ruger
Knight f3 yeah but that's it difficult
to play I mean I saw this move but I
didn't really see a clear-cut way to
that how he wins and it looked very a
chat very problematic though we're here
King f3 is winning for white okay Jim
yeah what can you do I only have ever
owned a limited time kounya three wins
but they're difficult to establish I was
of course afraid of Bishop Jaguar but it
seems that what can take take p.m. no
it's a draw okay which means that which
means that why does not winning outside
we have three the computer wasn't
calculating deep enough so my hunch was
was okay I only thought that this might
might lose for me but it seems to be a
draw unless the computers correcting
itself yet again no look a faint yeah
what's its King position is it's a total
disaster in a blitz game I mean how to
how should you ever play this
okay dear Bishop g4 is the killer a
bishop H flow is the killer and I went I
went TM okay this is also not helping
Queen III check T I just thought we gave
aid and I'm probably toast somehow
computer is still not seeing when maybe
there is no win but I thought that who
conveyed would be a very big problem it
just looks terrible that the final piece
is joining the tech computer is only
giving this is minus 1 which surprises
me maybe it needs some some more depth
in calculation to recognize that's maybe
even even more advantageous for for
black yet yeah I'm just totally lost
yeah I just overlooked Queen B 6 which
is which is very very annoying if we
consider that day that he made this this
is this this blunder you know okay look
it was it wasn't it was an ok game early
i cannot really am criticize me too much
for what was happening up to here but
only an idea three and and really that's
it I'm always coming here to block any
sort of activity and then it's not just
a pawn it's also a big position and
advantage shown this is the main problem
okay thanks for watching